an open mind is a very precious thing
and it should never be given away
perhaps ever certainly never lightly the
truth can take care of itself it does
not require your belief the truth need
not be treated as fragile you can beat
on the truth with bare peen hammers and
it will do just fine thank you so it one
should be respectful in the presence of
truth but not or something like that the
truth wants to be appreciated it wants
to be known it can take care of itself
belief is toxic and beliefs don't
believe in anything live in the presence
of the felt fact of immediate experience
everything beyond that is conjecture in
contemporary society we are always in
the past and in the future that what is
real our feelings and feelings obtain
the Nexus only in the moment only in the
moment so you know explore the edges
keep your logical razors short trust
nothing that you haven't clarified for
yourself and my faith is that the
universe will take you in and share with
you its meaning and its intent and its
conclusion so that's it thank you very
much
you